what's happened over the last
couple of months is we've had to modify
almost every aspect of training
stop punching your face we still
have the same mission to turn civilians
into the future of the coast guard to
the same standards to get out there to
conduct coast guard missions
but we've had to modify quite a few
things according to captain kathy felger
of the united states coast guard there
have been
zero confirmed cases of covid 19 at the
training center in cape may new jersey
but recruit training has seen drastic
transformations because of the pandemic
the coast guard provided this footage
that shows what recruit training is like
during the crisis when they arrive we do
temperatures we look for symptoms we ask
the same basic questions under the
guidance of the cdc
they're monitored daily and anybody that
does present symptoms fever coughing etc
will get tested for kobit 19.
upon arrival in cape may a new policy
known as restriction of movement
or rom keeps incoming recruits
quarantined for 14
days before they begin their training
and training looks a lot
different from when we visited cape may
in november of 2018
long before physical distancing became
the norm
[Applause]
this is what it looked like when
recruits arrived in 2018
and this is what it looks like now
our normal company size is anywhere from
100 to 120 and under this new process
we're only bringing in 48 to 50 and
that's based on
safety basically and what we could
isolate here in the event that we did
have
an outbreak of covet so we've reduced
the size of the company significantly
this officer right and how can you tell
them
so during this two-week restriction of
movement period the staff that's working
with them they can still instill
the discipline in the squad bay but not
in a intense disciplinarian environment
the lessons that they're getting are
about obeying orders following rules
learning their coast guard recruit
regulations a little bit of light
physical fitness so they're getting some
of the content of the curriculum
in this period without the intensity
once rom
ends recruits begin their regular
six-week training program
albeit with some limitations
after the two weeks it's presumed you
know we've mitigated the risk as much as
possible
the company commanders will be
maintaining that physical distance
if the company commander needs to engage
and be closer than six feet to a recruit
they will wear a mask and engage that
way
but the recruits themselves will still
be in close quarters training that's
part of the team building getting them
to march together close order drill
one place physical distancing is
strictly enforced
is the galley where recruits eat their
meals or chow
this footage from 2018 shows what chao
used to look like
and this is what it looks like during
kovid 19.
one of the biggest impacts is how the
crisis has affected graduations
as you can see in this footage from 2018
graduation ceremonies are normally an
emotional
celebratory occasion attended by friends
and loved ones
but amid the pandemic it's a much
different affair
each ceremony is live streamed on
facebook
on a normal graduation we might have a
hundred views recently
i think we had up to 900 because all the
families aunts
uncles grandma and grandpa are watching
from home having watch parties instead
of being there to celebrate in person
that's been the biggest change for us
and we don't see that changing for the
foreseeable future
we're trying to still put the same
product out to the coast guard that we
have young men and women ready to
operate ready to conduct coast guard
missions and we have to be able to
assure that they're meeting those
graduation standards so we have not
really modified the product that we're
giving out
just the way that they're training in
some environments